金ちゃん肇社長ですはいというわけで今日はですね大空ではないんだけど僕の友達の
繁盛3でございます他の部屋で遊んでるんですけども
まあねちょっとねああ
まず貼りたくねぇ
ぜってーバレたくでるってバレたけど f 静かな声でやりましょうちょっと本当に
バレたくないんで
何かとお世話になっている友達なので絶対に桜井ぞしたいんすよ僕はねほんとで
ちょっとそいつにはでまず色々世話になってるからちょっとねパパスペシャルを感じて
もらいたいですよクラッカーを100個
準備しましたこれを1個競ってパンパンやっても実に面白くないし
なんで今回ですね洗濯用のかごのこの穴ですねこのな肉なったを一歩させていきます攻
塔戦ナバスに同線の橋でポンとさせていきますいいんじゃないこういう感じでね全部さ
せた後にこの中の合成を全部旬で紐でうまいことこう結んで一本の太い当選しますそれ
を引っ張りまぁ百発がバーンとカーンと出るわけですやも感動して何
ぴゅあふるクラッカーとしていきましょう
ひとまず全部させましたんこんな感じでございます
うん
はいここからなんですけども中の銅線をつなげ作業に入りますちょっとこのたいので
わけわからないかもしれませんがフレーズ公園の西を全部1つにまとめます
なるべく頑張ってみまーす2つずつペアを作ってるんだよ
作戦としては2人一組でペアを作っていきます
は
ああ待って
しんどいは俺なんでこんな持つんだろう
ああああああ
me
ok どうでしょうかひとまず全部結びを得ました
完璧ですばっちりなら結び目の杭てやってるところを糸で通してひとまとめにしていき
ます
スネは通していきましょう
よし俺やばいでは業者さんからこれはね成功するとかわかんない塗ってお願い4本ませ
んにまとめたんですよ全部のせんよさらに1つにまとめます
ん阿含かごめんなさい5分だったどうだこういう感じだここでこここれがもう今全部の
動画さんにつながっています全部やれてるよね
すべてが一つの飛ばせにまとまったのでじゃあさっそくあそこお友達の誕生日という
ことで落下100発を一気について幸せな誕生日を迎えしてあげましょうね y子
マジでうまくいってほしいよん
もうすぐ部屋に来るのでちょっとイチかバチかなんですけどキミてみようと思います
ん
俺どう rear
car
ええええええ
rar
ano ano
俺
ああああああこれをする人だけどうぞ
えっじゃあいつぐらいからぞいいぞ
やれやれ正規とかもらったからさ